Long before it hit theaters, Avengers: Infinity
War had Marvel fans guessing who would live,
who would die, and what would happen if, and
when, Thanos got his hands on the Infinity
Stones.
Now that the movie’s out, though, the speculation
hasn’t stopped, and some fans have a new
theory that might change everything… in
the unlikely event that it’s actually true.
If you haven’t seen Infinity War yet, be
careful: we’re about to get into some deep
spoiler territory.
One of the most shocking moments of the film
comes right at the start, when Thanos kills
Loki, Thor’s occasionally supervillainous
brother.
It certainly seems like a definitive end to
Tom Hiddleston’s fan-favorite character,
but since we’ve seen Loki die before and
return through trickery and illusions, a few
moviegoers are wondering if there might be
something more than meets the eye going on
here.
A new theory brought up by journalist Josh
L. Dickey, mapped out in detail by ScreenRant's
Thomas Bacon, suggests that Loki didn't actually
die.
Instead, he's alive and well, and masquerading
as Bruce Banner.
Dickey notes that "Loki's dagger sneak attack
on Thanos was feeble.
He knew it wouldn't work,” suggesting that
the whole thing was a ruse to allow Loki to
sneak back onto Earth.
Further evidence comes from the view that
aside from not being able to turn into the
Hulk, there was something a little bit off
about Banner in the rest of the movie.
"I don’t know.
Maybe the fact that I was trapped for two
years inside of a monster made me a little
weird!"
According to the theory, he’s particularly
odd in his passion-less interactions with
Black Widow It’s been a few years since
their romance was teased in Avengers: Age
of Ultron, but since Banner doesn’t remember
the years he spent as the Hulk, those memories
should be pretty fresh in his mind.
The theory also posits that Banner's inner
struggle with Hulk may actually be down to
Loki disguising himself as the super-smart
scientist but being unwilling to impersonate
the not-so-jolly giant, thanks to their somewhat
contentious history with each other.
Dickey also suggests that this might be the
reason why Banner landed directly in Doctor
Strange's Sanctum Sanctorum when he returned
to Earth.
Loki has encountered the Master of the Mystic
Arts before, so it's possible that he may
have directed his path from outer space towards
Doctor Strange, knowing he’d be a quality
choice to spearhead the fight against Thanos.
If all this is true, it could mean that the
Hulk wasn’t even on the Asgardian refugee
ship at the start of Infinity War, escaping
with Valkyrie, the breakout character of Thor:
Ragnarok who’s expected to return in a future
MCU film.
The only problem is that, well, it’s probably
not true at all.
If you take Occam’s Razor to the Loki-As-Banner
theory, you’ll find there’s a much simpler
explanation for all of its points.
For starters, by the time Thanos shows up
on the Asgardian ship, he’s already dealt
with Loki before, and knows how he operates.
He’d be prepared for and expecting deceptive
tactics like illusions and shapeshifting.
Second, and probably most importantly, Banner’s
struggles with the Hulk make a lot more sense
as Banner actually struggling with the Hulk
rather than Loki working a long con on the
Avengers.
The Hulk’s encounter with Thanos marks the
first time that the Green Goliath has been
so easily defeated in a fight, which would
shatter his confidence and explain why he’s
so unwilling to make a return.
Also, there are several scenes in Infinity
War where Banner attempts to turn into the
Hulk when no one is around to see it.
That would only make sense for Loki if he
suddenly had Deadpool levels of fourth wall-breaking
self-awareness.
Banner’s arrival at the Sanctum Sanctorum
is pretty easy to explain away with magic,
but probably happened because that scene is
lifted from the original comics.
The only difference is that there, it’s
the Silver Surfer who ruins Strange’s staircase,
but since he doesn’t currently exist in
the MCU, Banner makes a fitting substitute.
As for Banner’s encounter with Black Widow,
there actually is some tension there, but
it’s certainly not the focus.
That, however, is easily explained by the
fact that the romance teased in Age of Ultron
wasn’t exactly the best part of that movie.
Some viewers felt like it came out of nowhere,
and didn’t really serve either character
well, so it makes sense that the next film
might downplay it.
Or maybe Bruce Banner just doesn’t prefer
blondes.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!